welcome to the series of global
governance today we are going to discuss
the challenges to security and stability
in the region of the Black Sea very
challenging region traditionally very
challenging with different geopolitical
geographical challenges so and today I
am pleased to introduce our two
panelists very important panelists
first of all ambassador Bulgaria Yuri
the look of Panayiotis good good friend
and a very active ambassador in the
United Nations what is a very important
his experience he served for several
years in Afghanistan Wow
in a very crucial year so that's why if
you move out the Black Sea he's the best
expert on that well but generate he's an
expert on the region he's reading from
he knows everything about the challenges
which are both military both political
both economic energy challenges so we
are going to speak about all of them and
my good compatriot general Yuri Kravitz
who is recently joined the Ukrainian
mission to United Nations he's the head
of Ukrainian military mission to United
Nations previously to that he was air
military attache in Washington so he
knows everything about the military
component of the challenges in the Black
Sea with all recent developments and so
we count on him to share with us on on
what is going corn balances checks and
balances in these balances in the region
so with that because people will come in
from anywhere we we have a web coverage
as always so that's why all the Ivy
League universities you have
a chance to observe all your questions
the answers and with that I would like
to ask ambassador in order to to start
up a discussion and to make to make his
presentation well thank you thank you
good afternoon everybody thank you for
being here today and thank you for
taking your time most isthmus and I'd
like thank you for this came whose
introduction I would like to stress that
besides having spent five years of my
life in Afghanistan as a deputy chief
mission at the Bulgarian embassy in the
year I used to get our NATO Department
at home at the Ministry of Foreign
Affairs and I dealt in details with the
security in the so called broader Black
Sea region today I'm going to focus my
presentation exactly on that you are
very well aware of the geographical
location of the Black Sea region oops
this doesn't work okay oops here we are
here we are
but nevertheless I prepared this slide
immediately I would like to correct the
map because the capital of Ukraine in
Ukrainian language is not being spelled
like Kiev but like kief so this on the
map is wrong and here we have a country
which is called Macedonia which is not
exactly correct as you know due to the
agreement sienten presper between greece
and north macedonia the latter changed
its name because this was the way
for the authorities in North Macedonia
to clear their path to Brussels that is
to say to the integration into the
European Union and to the euro-atlantic
integration that is to say to NATO the
Black Sea region why we are talking
today about the Black Sea region I'm not
going to read from the slides but it is
central that this region first has been
for a very long time not in the center
of the attention of the euro-atlantic
institutions why because immediately
after the fall of the Soviet Union the
Turkish fleet Turkey is a NATO member
state and he has the second biggest army
in NATO the Turkish fleet actually was
superseding the Black Sea Fleet of the
Soviet Union now well go back to the
slides
no sorry for that yeah here and now come
closer to the map thank you thank you
first of all let's have a closer look
what are the Black Sea littoral states
we have three NATO member states Romania
Bulgaria Turkey as I mentioned Turkey
has the second biggest army in NATO very
important ally a key ally Bulgaria
Romania Bulgaria Romania at the same
time our EU member states turkey is not
turkey is an aspirant country they are
negotiating their EU membership we have
Ukraine we have Russia we have Georgia
here is Crimea which now has been
occupied by the Russian Federation part
of Georgia this map is not correct in
this again probably I have to choose
another one map whatever here we have
two Republic's which have been
recognized only by the Russian
Federation South Ossetia and Abkhazia
after as a results of the Russian and
Georgian war Georgia lost those
territories and South Ossetia and
Abkhazia are independent that is to say
totally under Russian control because
nobody else recognizes them this country
is central and I will tell you why I
think so
the black sea is a very important
intersection because it is a
communication transportation an energy
corridor in two directions west east and
north south the black sea gives Russia
the possibility to jump into the regions
of the eastern Mediterranean to project
its influence on the Balkans in Caucasus
as well as in the northern Middle East
all post-soviet conflicts I'll go back
to the slides with the map the map is
loading slowly all the post-soviet spurt
rekted conflicts in moldova Transnistria
here as I mentioned North occasi and
South Ossetia eastern Ukraine and now
the occupied Crimea they are all
concentrated around the Black Sea Black
Sea for Russia traditionally
historically was the way out to an open
seat to the mid Mediterranean it was
Russian ambition since centuries to
control the Straits the Bosphorus in the
Dardanelles or like the Turks call them
the turkey straits
I see somebody was laughing but the name
of the Straits actually was a very
important point of dispute within NATO
between Turkey and the other member
states
but I call them Bosphorus in the
Dardanelles just a couple of years ago
Russia tried to gain control over a
naval base in Montenegro he'll pour
Girija that has been denied by the
Montenegrin authorities we all know that
now Russia has a naval base in the
Mediterranean Tartus in Syria so
Russia's ambitions were to control the
Straits so to secure the link of the
closed Black Sea to the Mediterranean
and later to the world sea to the ocean
and as I mentioned the Black Sea is a
very important intersection of energy
corridors back to the slide there are
several energy corridors already in
place the first one is the so-called
blue stream connecting Russia with the
this part of Turkey another one the
turkey stream is connecting Russia with
the European part of Turkey
not far away from Istanbul there is
another oil pipeline because the first
two are gas pipelines
there is a third pipeline called by Baku
Jahan going from Baku in Azerbaijan
through Georgia bypassing Armenia to the
port of jaehyun which is on the
Mediterranean these two corridors first
the blue stream and the second the
turkey stream are doing what they're
bypassing this territory Ukraine on
Ukrainian territory there is a gas
pipeline called Druzhba the Russians
just want to bypass Ukraine and to
marginalize the importance of Ukraine in
the energy trades in Europe last year in
2018 despite the efforts of the European
Commission Russia transported
record amount of gas to Europe using
including these gas pipelines here and
they are building another pipeline which
is called North stream going directly to
Germany that one the North stream is
bypassing Poland so as you can see
Russia is using energy as a policy
leverage as a leverage in its foreign
policy but this is part of the reality
the other part of the reality is that
Russia is using not only energy Russia
is using also corruption Russia is using
rivalries within the European Union and
within the allies within NATO in order
to split them now who are the main
players when we are talking about the
security of the Black Sea region
first of all NATO as you know NATO is
the most successful political military
military alliance in the world
comprising 29 States USA Canada in 27
European states NATO is an alliance
political military I would like to
stress that not only military because if
article 5 is the backbone of the
alliance that is that the attack against
one would be an attack against all then
article 4 which talks about negotiations
and consultations it is it soul
so NATO has a key role in the security
around Black Sea but at the same time
that role is limited why because we have
the mentor convention according to the
Montreux convention that is an
international document no foreign vessel
military vessel has the right to stay in
the Black Sea more than 45 days if that
vessel does not belong to any of the
littoral countries littoral States that
is to say if a u.s. Canadian panitch UK
military ship would like to enter Black
Sea first it requires the permission of
Turkey and it cannot spend more than 45
days in the Black Sea
so NATO has to think out of the box what
to do
just recently during the NATO
ministerial in held in Washington DC the
NATO ministers agreed a package of
measures to improve NATO's situational
awareness in the Black Sea region and
strengthen support for partners Georgia
and Ukraine
once again the Alliance has to find way
how to best do that because the Montreal
Convention is practically prohibiting
that is not allowing it a NATO is
important because NATO is the
organization with hard military
infrastructure and hurt military
capabilities the other player the
European Union doesn't have any hard
military capabilities European Union has
not been designed to be defense alliance
the European Union has soft security
power European Union is very solid when
it comes to development when it comes to
human rights when it comes to
humanitarian aid but the European Union
is still a dwarf when it comes to
military power although most of the
European countries are NATO members the
European Union has an instrument called
Eastern Partnership with the
participation of Ukraine Georgia Moldova
Armenia Azerbaijan and Belarus all but
Belarus are part of the so-called
broader Black Sea area and this
instrument aims a building a common area
of democracy prosperity stability and
cooperation we are trying to solidify
democracy in those countries to make
them partners and to try to avoid
conflicts but still the mediation the
role of the European Union as a mediator
is limited
you can read that in its global strategy
in 2016 the union describe defined
identified the conflicts in the Black
Sea region as a challenge to the
European security order identifying his
one thing doing something about this
completely other thing the European
Union lacks the tools to do that
that's why I placed NATO in the first
place another player that of course are
the United States of America
traditionally involved in European
developments since World War one but
more significantly after the Second
World War the United States are a
leading country in NATO actually the
Alliance is the most powerful political
military alliance because of the unique
military capabilities of the United
States of America the European countries
are lagging behind in technology and
military kit capabilities from the
United States of America now they are
trying to close that gap but it will
take a lot of time it will take a lot of
investment and it will take a lot of
political will which right now in Europe
it call is concentrated somewhere else
I'll come to that later Russia I told
you it has been historically Russian
foreign policy goal to control the
straits of the Black Sea that's why they
had several wars with Turkey at the time
the both countries were empires actually
as a result of one of those wars
Bulgaria regained its independence but
it was not the main goal of Russia to
liberate the area
it was Russia's goal to
[Music]
put the straights under control
nevertheless we regained our
independence we are grateful for that
turkey
I talked very much about NATO why I
singled out Turkey because turkey is a
very specific case you know it that
right now there is a deepening tension
between Turkey and the leading country
in NATO the United States over the
desire of Turkey to purchase Russian
mate systems c400 the United States and
frankly all the other allies are
convinced that this is against the very
spirit of the Alliance to buy weapons
from your adversary because NATO at the
end of the day was created to counter
the aspirations of the Soviet Union in
Europe and now one of the most important
allies turkey is trying is not trying
they signed a deal to purchase very
sophisticated anti-aircraft systems
called c400 turkey is a very ambitious
country especially under President
Erdogan it's a very big country it has
very strategic location between European
Asia
it has demographic boom he has over 80
million people the population of Turkey
is over 8 million turkey Turkey's
ambitions are to be regional leader to
dominate the region
and of course it's their right to have
such ambitions they also would like I
think to Don
the shear world not only the region but
to dominate the shear world why because
in the times of the Ottoman Empire a
very large part of the shear world is
actually part of that Empire they have
historic connections they have the
tradition they have the faith they have
in many in many cases the same history
same past and same present because the
Arab countries are one of the main trade
partner of Turkey nowadays and now I
have two players with question marks
first is the OSCE and the second is
China why question marks because oh I
see before the Ukrainian conflict
conflict was practically on the
organization in decline marginalized
organization the oisi has been created
during this the Cold War to be the
bridge between the East and the West to
be the round table for talks between the
East and the West with the fall of the
Iron Curtain that role vanished to a
greater extent but with the Ukrainian
conflict conflict that role we emerged
again oscy turned out to be the only
organization to have some role in
Ukraine in eastern Ukraine and still the
OSI mission in Ukraine as I put it here
on the slide is called special
monitoring mission in a brain what do
they do they monitor yes they meet all
the players there they meet the Russian
side they meet the cranial side they try
to be mediators they try to avoid
escalation of the conflict but still
they are monitoring
there were ideas to start a UN mission
in Ukraine but the concept of Russia for
UN mission and the concept of
[Music]
practically the rest of the world about
that mission was totally different
probably my Ukrainian colleagues will go
deep into that in China
question mark is China player in the
European security in general and in the
security of Black Sea region I don't
know but I know the Chinese the only
country in the world which has a global
strategy
neither the European Union has a global
strategy although there is on this slide
the 2016 year's global strategy but it
encounters a lot of challenges the USA
right now does the United States have a
global strategy I don't think so that's
Russia have a global strategy I don't
think so
so China is the only country in the
world with the global strategy they have
that very interesting project the belt
and rold initiative the Chinese the both
the belt in Rose wrote Initiative is a
project which actually promotes the
connection between China and the West
but that is
connected to another thing heavy Chinese
investment in critical infrastructure
everywhere on the road and the recent
experience from the results of those
efforts of Beijing in some countries
like Sri Lanka for example is very
negative
nevertheless one EU member-states Italy
recently declared that it will
participate in that project the European
Union as such in my country as well we
said no but Italy agreed and right now
together with the Chinese they are going
to build a port in the Mediterranean I
think in the town of Trieste so still
I'm not quite sure whether China is a
player in the security and stability of
the Black Sea region but it certainly
would have such ambitious in near future
here
I prepared a list of the Russia's Black
Sea Fleet but I'm not going to elaborate
on the submarine ships and boats the
more important thing is that in the 2015
maritime doctrine of the Russian
Federation the Russian Black Sea Fleet
has one major task and that is to ensure
Russian sovereignty over Crimea
Russia nowadays has very sophisticated
military capabilities in the Black Sea
thanks to its occupation of Crimea
Crimea is like second Kaliningrad sake
second kenigsberg it's the largest
aircraft carrier in the world a to ad
this is a military air gun probably the
general I'm sure knows about it pro land
most of you do but a 2a d stands for
entire access area denial that is to say
that in Crimea and not only but mainly
in Crimea Russian military possesses
long courage anti-air and a tight ship
systems and sensor systems which cover
virtually all of the black sea they have
aircrafts and those aircrafts both
fighters and fighter bombers play power
projection role their electronic warfare
potential is very up-to-date and as I
already mentioned the Russian Black Sea
Fleet is actually the muscles for
Russian power projection in the eastern
Mediterranean why a2/ad
by possessing such capabilities Russia
practically controls and is capable to
hit that is to say to destroy everything
what moves in the Black Sea including
vessels and aircrafts of NATO member
states
that is why the North Atlantic Treaty
Organization has to find a way how to
increase its presence in the Black Sea
and to help the partners Georgia and
Ukraine it will not be easy
here I came to the main challenges which
you can read from the screen it's clear
that the center of gravity in the world
is shifting and the direction is from
west to east
make no mistake there's not vice-versa
it is from west to east Europe
what is now the condition of Europe
brexit immigration we have emerging non
liberal democracies that's a new term
relatively for Europe I mean what we
have emerging known liberal democracies
in Europe
I mean EU Member States
the Brits are still thinking what to do
with their decision to leave the
European Union they practically are
sailing and chartered waters they don't
know what to do and nobody knows because
it's happening for the first time but
it's very painful for both the UK and
the rest of Europe
and rashes if evolving resurgence just
years ago we have been talking about
Russia's resurgence it continues that's
an ongoing process
needless to say what the Muller report
was about needless to say that it has
been proved that if not the Russian
government but hackers somewhere in
Russia caused disruption of the Estonian
bank system years ago that's why in
Estonia now we have cyber center which
is designed to counter cyber cyber
threats and once again Russia is using
everything it can in order to promote
its interest everything on the book
everything especially energy there is
another challenge here i permitted
myself to put it here because i believe
in it the u.s. foreign policy its future
is uncertain
in the last couple of years there were a
lot of statements coming from the US
administration and good part of them
were not very nice about America's
allies that includes my country not
particularly that nobody talked about
Korea but European Union NATO it is true
that America America's burden is the
heaviest in NATO that is without any
doubt but it has been decided in during
the times of the former administration
that all the other allies that was the
NATO summit in Wales that all the other
allies will increase their expenses for
military purposes
to up to two percent of their GDP and we
are doing that including my country and
even the slightest signals from
Washington is very painful for us
because America is our strategic partner
they are the main ally it was because
America and the West that Eastern Europe
fought for freedom because freedom is
not merely a word and 50 years old I
lived under communism believe me freedom
is not merely a word freedom is much
more than a word
energy in security I touched upon that
and the eternal challenges in every
single country we have rise of
nationalism we have rise of populism
which is not helpful at the moment so
I'm done with the presentation and I'm
ready to answer your question we have
okay
all right presentation of the general
and it and then we come to the all right
the question so I can't take this is
yours
where are you so thank you very much for
your attention once again thank you
bachelor panayotov thank you your give
for comprehensive presentation you touch
upon practically all the major issues
and challenges now I'm putting the new
the new slides for the next presentation
here thank you we'll come back to the
the major players in the in the region
you mentioned all of them Russia Turkey
NATO is here is here well no general
Kravitz you you have you have floor well
thank you from the table I oh thank
laughs and again ladies and gentlemen at
first I'd like to express my gratitude
for disappearing to be with with you at
this renowned institution and I said
this is my task to share with you the
previous one and a previous one they
begin previous malenko's Neil yeah I'd
like to share with you some thoughts
about the ongoing aggression Russian a
group military aggression to my country
and to take up at the that moocher
aggression against against Ukraine is a
vivid demonstration of the Russian
overall challenge to peace and stability
in Eastern Europe I would like to stick
to the and concentrate my remarks to the
mutual instrument of power which Russia
rather skillfully used against my
country I would like from from the
outset I'd like to emphasize that those
who has to deal with Russia who usually
face it dilemma or what to believe to
believe in what russia says or in what
russia does hello look please said at
that slide on the one hand you could he
could probably have heard that the chief
of the Russian armed forces General
Staff General Valeri grassy moe made
several interesting statements in inside
in a speech at the Russian Academy of
military Sciences on March the 2nd 2019
and I'll read them for you
the Pentagon has started developing a
completely new strategy of military
action which has already been christened
the Trojan horse it's its essence lies
in the active use of the fifth column
protests potential to disturb allies the
situation along with simultaneous
precision strikes on the
most important targets the United States
and its allies are developing an
offensive military action such as a
global strike and multi-domain battle
and I using the technologists of color
revolution and soft power and the use
goal is the liquidation of the statehood
of undesirable countries do we have to
believe in those words we have to judge
Russia's international policy upon its
deeds say in Georgia in 2008 or nowadays
Ukraine Syria or probably when Israel I
did I press something probably okay in
essence next slide please
[Music]
in essence as we see it Russia tries to
create new tension zones in Europe and
in the in the Mediterranean in order to
rearrange the existing system of
international relations so that Moscow
could regain the role of some dominant
power which is crucial to the very
sustainability of Putin's regime inside
Russia itself acting that way Kremlin is
counting on getting new spheres of
influence as well as on the restoration
of control or with the post-soviet
states or over what in the Russian
parlance is called me abroad one of the
main instruments with Russia Russia uses
to this end is its armed forces and in
some sense I would argue that mr. Putin
during all this time in power has spared
no effort in reviving the Russian
military might sincerely believing in
what he in April 2015 said to the
Russian population in a televised
address when he referred to some a -
attributed to the Russian Emperor
Alexander the third who once said that
Russia has just only two allies
its army and it's Navy next slide please
by widening the geography and scale with
military engagements Russia by putting
boots on the ground creates new
political realities on the ground trying
to achieve Kremlin geopolitical
objectives and we can trace evolution of
the Russian geopolitical and
patience through the evolution of the
Russian Armed Forces general speaking
since the collapse of the Soviet Union
the Russian armed forces operationally
he walls through the following stages
from quasi peacekeeping operations of
the Russian military after the collapse
of the USSR in transdniestria appraisee
and the search in 1991 to 1993 through
two chechen wars inside russia in 1994
1996 and 1999 talk 22 mm respectively to
defensive operations of the russian
military in the the so called nearly
brought in Georgia in 2008 in Ukraine
since 2014 and the offensive operation
of the Russian military in the far
abroad for instance in Syria which has
been ongoing since 2015
next latest in a wider perspective what
we as the military see at present is
that Russia prepares for a full-scale
war by modernizing the strategic nuclear
forces in order to increase their
capability of penetrating missile
defenses by creating strategic
non-nuclear forces by creating
self-sufficient into service groupings
in the northwest western south western
and eastern regions Russia increased is
increasing the scale and intensity of
operational and mobilization training it
creates a single national Ashland air
and missile defense system and it
employs nonlinear warfare methods
it also creates a strategic electronic
wallet Roenick warfare systems and it
will immense the concept of
expeditionary forces power projection
and distant territories and finally as
we believe Russia is preparing its
economy to function at time of war this
is an overall context next slide whereas
the context of my country I would say
Russia continues to amass its
conventional troops near the state
border almost all around Ukraine
creating really real military stress to
my country and the situation is
extremely unfavorable for my native land
since the Kremlin has already got a real
opportunity to launch an OP
armed aggression side Ukraine without
the need for additional redeployment or
without forces from other parts of
Russia in fact about 70% of the
Ukrainian Russian border borders is a
contact line with our military opponent
such a situation allows Russia to carry
out flank strikes simultaneously as you
can see in the slide from three
different directions to this end the
Kremlin amassed alone our mutual border
is a grouping of military forces - about
18,000 troops and and the rest you can
see the numbers and according to the
plans of the Russian command until 2028
the strength of this group and will
increase by third so if Russia starts
its open aggression the existing group
20 Russian forces will allow to get an
access to the rear of our forces it will
cut off Ukraine from its western borders
and thus from any move to the support
from our NATO partners through those
borders next slide please since in 2014
the number of combat units in the border
regions of Russia has more than tripled
including the formation without the
combined arms army and motorized rifle
division in its structure
in total the number of infantry and tank
regiments increased from 2 to 12 and
during the next two years we expect to
see the deployment of the 3rd combined
arms army one more division and at least
four brigades and six regiments of the
ukrainian direction under such condition
russia is capable of launching is
already set in a sudden offensive
against ukraine without showing any sign
of preparation since some elements of
the strike forces are already
concentrated at a distance less than 50
kilometers from the border of Ukraine in
the course of such an offensive both
naval and ground-based cruise missiles
as well as strategic aviation along with
the combined arms armies the
conventional weaponry can be used next
slide please and we shouldn't forget
that the Russian military already inside
Ukraine in the east of my country where
two Army Corps one for the nets another
one for Lugansk region are stationed
those two Army Corps
constitute the bulk of the Russian
occupation of force inside Ukraine they
have been created they armed and
equipped trained and maintained under
Russian templates and there are under
strict command and control of the
Russian chain of command going from the
southern neutral district up to the
Russian general staff in Moscow so in
other words Russia has already created
conditions for its long term military
presence in Ukraine this is a more or
less known fact next slide please
what is less known though is that those
two i'ma Corps are part-and-parcel the
Russian joint task force created in the
southern new to the district and the
commander of the 8th army of that
Military District is dual headed it
being also a commander of the Joint Task
Force which is to operate on the
so-called dawn operational direction
within thousand Western strategic
direction in the Russian military
parlance in practicals mean in practical
terms for the Russian military it means
that the occupied part of the on vast
area of Ukraine is already part of the
geography of the southern neutral
district and the part of that
ukrainian-russian border which we do not
control because of the occupation is
non-existent for the Russians for all
intents and purposes these are the facts
which Russians try hard to conceal
otherwise all Russian propaganda
phraseology about something bust people
raising their arms against the key one
junta would lose its appeal next as I
already mentioned Russia would probably
use both naval and ground-based cruise
missiles as well as strategic evasion in
its inventory when when and if it
decides to launch an open offensive
against Ukraine we believe so because
Russia continues to enlarge a pool of
carriers of high-precision weaponry such
as ground and naval base cruise missiles
for instance the current concept of the
development of the armed forces of
Russia
stipulates that each combined arms army
or Army Corps of the ground forces
should have a unit of Iskandar in nato
designation ss 26 stone mobile
short-range ballistic missile system in
this structure we know that in December
2018 the formation of 72nd separate
but telling a whisk and you are
short-range ballistic missile system in
the structure of the 8th army of the
southern cultural district started it is
planned that the missile brigade will be
created in due time in its stead similar
measures are expected to be implemented
in the structure of the 22nd i'ma Corps
which integrates all Russian ground
forces and occupied Crimea the high
command of the armed forces of Russia is
in dead earnest about getting by the
Year 2021 an increase in the number of
carriers of cruise missiles around the
board of Ukraine in two times and number
of missiles into 2.4 times next slide
please
and here you can see that depleted the
deployment of the black sea fleet of
rush of new combat ships with calibre
land attack cruise missiles is underway
and at present the black sea fleet both
of 5we on m-class cruise missile
Corvettes and six improved kilo diesel
submarines those combat ships with
calibre land attack cruise missiles
regularly perform combat missions in the
eastern Mediterranean near Syria next
slide on the other hand Russia continues
to modernize its aerospace forces by
equipping them with modern aircraft and
improving the airdrome Network new
Russian strike planes have an extended
range and as you can see news to high
30s m and Soho 84 planes are capable of
using onboard weapons at the targets at
Central European states and one great
strategic launches launchers bombers
tupelo 160 and tuple night--if 95 m/s
and tuple 22 m3 in non-nuclear equipment
may be also used together with tactical
aircraft in the second half of the 2018
we noticed an increased by 30 percent
compared to the same period of 2017 of
the intensity of flights of Russian
operational and tactical aviation of
both western and southern neutral
districts next slide please overall
general speak and special attention
should be paid to the fact that Russia
uses the Black Sea region as a
springboard for proliferation of Russian
influence to the media terrain
which how the excellency already alluded
to
well the objectives of Moscow in the
Black Sea region are as follows as we
see not to let your eternal Crimea and
the Ukrainian jurisdiction to gain full
control over the Black Sea with the go
to influence the states of the region
and to counterbalance any u.s. NATO
actions in the Alliance's eastern flank
and provide for constant russian with
your presence in the mediterranean next
slide in this regard we should remember
that on December 17th 2018 the UN
General Assembly adopted the resolution
named on the issue of neutralization of
the autonomous Republic of Crimea and
Sevastopol and parts of black and Azov
seas in which the UN urges Russia to
withdraw its own forces from Crimea
expresses grave concern awaits Mountain
mood to the present and urges Russia to
stop with the legal occupation of the
part of the territory of Ukraine
however in relational international laws
Russia continues to the militarization
of the Crimea Russian Minister of
Defense conduct large-scale exercise of
airborne forces in the temporal crippied
Crimea including training of deployment
nuclear weapons of the territory of
temporary pride Crimea and preparing
them for combat use Russian Defense
Minister Choe who stated once that
Russia has enhanced combined control
structures in a compared Crimea in its
in his turn the chairman of Russia State
Duma Defense Committee shaman or Shimano
recently stated that Russian tupelo 22m
three strategic bombers were deployed in
occupied Crimea
according to Shimano those the missile
aircraft and the one deep modernization
and a capable of destroying any target
in Europe head of the defense and
security committee of the Russian
Federation Council boundary also added
that Russia Crimea deployed this Condor
mobile short-range ballistic missiles
and the peninsula she also emphasized
the Tupolev 22mm three bombers and
cruise missiles can hit any spot in
europe and can destroy any element of
the enemy's missile or
air defenses by his words first the
modernization of Tupelo 22 m3 bombers
will selection of the new types of
ammunition will make the bomber
Universal means for air strikes at all
types of targets at the range of
thousands kilometers and in this case I
think we shouldn't miss the point and
they are boastful assertions ok next
time another direction of Kremlin
aggressive actions with the way Ukraine
is a Russian tried to acquire full
control over this he oversaw and and de
Lyon aims behind the Russian efforts to
control this year was all are as follows
first to revise Russian Ukrainian
borders after annexation of Crimea to
acquire full controller with the seed of
a solvent occur straight to block the
Ukrainian economic activity in the
region and been doing so to create
depression zones in the coastal area of
the Sea of Azov and provoke social
social economic stability and bring
pro-russian political forces back to
power in the region and finally to
pressure Ukraine to restore water supply
to occupied Crimea next IP and there is
a history behind Russia's current malign
efforts regarding this year was off we
should go back to 2003 when Russia tried
to erect the dam to the Ukrainian Tuzla
Island and by doing so they tried they
tried to impose the new borders in this
year was old at that time and the
Russian pressure Ukraine was forced to
conclude the agreement about common
usage of the Sea of Azov
which in fact removed the waters of the
Sea of Azov and catch tried from
jurisdiction of the unconventional the
law of the sea of 1982 next slide please
relying upon above-mentioned treaty in
2008 Russian Ukrainian Commission signed
a protocol determined median line of the
Sea of Azov according to which 62
percent of its water area shall belong
to Ukraine
however Russia's president rejected
agreement and demonstrated no intention
to complete the limitation of Ukrainian
Russian maritime border next slide here
here you can see it
the sea of azov water the limitation
schema which Russia tries to impose on
Ukraine and the visual state will
control only built of coastal waters not
more than 12 miles wide next like this
since April 2018 Russian Navy has been
conducting different actions for
impeding freedom of navigation and black
hair that we crane report summary upon
bergen skin the sea Rizzo by closing
certain areas of this year was Oh under
pretext of Russian naval exercises long
term delay of passage of commercial
vessels which had to of from Ukrainian
ports as it was out of intensive
inspection by Russian security forces
became a common practice the specific
attention Russian security forces pay to
wrestles with Ukrainian crew members
next lightly I would like to have your
attention to the design features of the
Crimean Crimean bridge which additional
limits the passage of vessels to the sea
of azov headroom of crimean bridge for
vessels movement is 35 meters may be
navigable depth 9 meters as a result of
this design features maximum air draught
of vessels moving in the sea of azov
limited by 33 meters and water dropped
by 8 meters next lightest such Russian
actions led to is leading to economic
losses of Ukraine through the
contraction of income of southern
regions of Ukraine specific and the
spheres of maritime transfers trade
industry and fishing has already cost
curtailment of cargo traffic of port of
Mariupol but 20% berdyansk by 43% and
reduced fishing in the Sea of Azov by
50% the lesson cargo traffic results in
worsening of situation in metallurgical
industry and reduced in size of still
export which is one of the main sources
of hard currency to the state budget we
would understand the part of
metallurgical industry products in the
structure of Ukraine export is near 25%
it's about 10 billion u.s. dollars next
slide please there is one more thing
Russia's after in this year was oh I'd
love it love to start extraction of
world gas
Berezovsky and indoor kubatski fuels
estimated olan gas talks and this year
was our equivalent to four hundred
thirteen million tons of oil next slide
please
you'll also see that Russia boosted its
activity in northwestern part of the
Black Sea which includes beefing up the
protection of the Seas decree on drill
platforms more intensive is our
operations as well as imposing stricter
control of maritime navigation by
declaring from time to time under the
pretext of naval exercises closed areas
near navigation routes for instance in
August 2018 the Russian Black Sea Fleet
conducted a naval exercise in the
northwestern part of Black Sea with
practice launches of caliber caliber sea
based cruise missiles and live artillery
fire for us it means that in crimea as
was in Kaliningrad region Russia is
creating new strategic nodes within its
global control NATO framework and
composition of Russian forces weapons
and munitions already deployed in Crimea
indicate that Russian military is
preparing for combat in the Black Sea
theater operations with the use of its
most sophisticated conventional weaponry
and ice our assets
next slide please distinguished
colleagues to conclude I'd like to
emphasize that people of Ukraine to be
proud of the acquaintance army which
stood up to the Russian military
encroaches inside Ukraine and there is a
growing consensus in Ukraine that there
is no military way to read of the
Russian occupation and that only
political and diplomatic action should
be used this way the UN should step in
but it's a separate topic of discussion
in this regard I would only reiterate
that the Ukrainian government supports
further implementation of the Minsk
agreement for peaceful settlement of
confident the dogmas and uses any
opportunity to call on Russia to stop
with aggression against Ukraine to
return the next Crimea immediately
released ukrainian sailors vessels and
equipment unlawfully captured in the
Black Sea on 25th of November 2018 and
restore freedom of shipping through the
caps ride and the Sea of Azov but this I
conclude
my presentation yeah thank you thank you
so ladies gentlemen mmm Oh start now for
question answers thank you to both of
our panelists for comprehensive
explanation was going cone so several
dimensions of the challenges so we we
had in front of us to discuss first of
all military-political so and that's
currently generally explained us what's
going on there I will I will start with
my questions and leave the questions to
to the to August audience audience well
to you so it is it is clear that the
main challenge now in the political
military challenge and dramatic changes
in the geostrategic
situation in in black sea happened after
the annexation of Crimea Russia got the
platform to to perform from this
platform as it was demonstrated in the
slides that for the past time from this
platform Russia attacked Georgia in 2008
having the Naval Base in Sevastopol and
then first ever after the collapse of
the Soviet Union when Russia
performed outside in Syria so before
that it was Afghanistan it was it was
well demonstrated so it is clear that
Russia is trying to return its return
the position of the Soviet Union and to
control us this all this region and to
recreate the the perimeter of their own
security and to create a buffer zones
Iran herself and then to play a role of
the original leader so me their tactics
if not a strategy I agree with
ambassador that it is very difficult to
define the strategy what Rush
has in mind global him just to keep
floating as the global leader creating
global crises and then to demand to
recognize their global role but it is
clear that in the region they are trying
to to return its influence to control
the periphery of interest they are doing
that through destabilizing of Ukraine it
is clear and they keep the stabilizing
of Ukraine it is clear that they are
paralyzing Moldova you know keeping the
mmm the proxies army proxies in
Transnistria it is clear that the the
subduing Georgia very clear supporting
different political forces there and
trying to put them in the orbit but it's
clear that they are trying to isolate
Romania Romania is one of the close
partners of of NATO in the region it is
clear
most probably ambassador will make a
clear picture but from my point of view
that Russia is trying to neutralize
Bulgaria through different means to
interfere in domestic political affairs
of something and what is clear from the
massive representation about the
particular energy insecurity energy
policy which Russia is playing they are
playing well to attract attention of
such countries as Turkey who is looking
their own leading role there and through
that mechanism to pacify Turkey to
pacify Turkey not to not a play at the
leading role in the NATO community in
the in in the region but the question is
that if to compare the budgets the
United States has the military budget
United States is more than 700 billion
trillions
not billions dollars close to 1 trillion
Chinese budget is 244 billion Russia
budget is only forty four billion but
still they are trying to play a role of
the biggest military power in the world
with 44 billion the combined budget of
all the literal states in the Black Sea
is many times less than Russian budget
my first question is now what are the
means I should be taken to detail Russia
to deter Russia because now it looks
like the main military political
challenge in the region but how to deter
very easy question
Russia is cooperating very closely with
Turkey and they are cooperating not only
in the energy sector they are
cooperating to gas pipelines built
already the second integrated with the
participation of President Putin in
Turkey and they also have military
cooperation as well and I'm not in
visiting only the desire of Turkey to
purchase that sophisticated c400 system
I am in visiting the cooperation in
Syria as well so how can we datura first
of all we have to solidify our ranks not
allow to allow Russia to split them to
play individually with us and these
girls for NATO members these girls for
EU members as well and what is the most
important thing I mean how to solidify
our ranks is very complicated question
by itself but we just have to stick to
our values we have to stick to our
values because what is the the biggest
difference difference between EU NATO
and Russia are the values agree with the
last last point that after the collapse
of the Soviet Union the liberal world
based on the values started to decline
interest interest started to to prevail
so that's why the former rivals from the
liberal world they are easily investing
in a liberal world non-communist 20
communist countries investing in the
communist countries so values
disappeared and so now we are to to
review what our hours are I agree with
that so so this is a complicated
complicated complicated to ask but again
so the
the military power of Russia is growing
as general demonstrators in in the
region so and what are the possibilities
for the liberal states - well at least -
to reach the level of when the can it
not not only to defend but to deter
there's a question and not easy question
first of all I would agree with the
everything was said about the values
which which means a lot in the in this
should means should mean a lot and in
this in this time because alluding to I
mean trying to answer your previous
question is for what can be done about
the Russia's intentions or actions I
would argue that first it should be
clear understanding of the threat which
in my and my understand is that Russia
very skillfully switches from one from
using one instrumental power beat
military in terms of 2008 in Georgia or
2014 in Ukraine to economic pressure by
but that oil hero cabinets
transportation issues as the Ambassador
Luda - or when it informational we're
full
aware of that the aptitude of the
Russian propaganda which actually has a
good background in the Soviet soil
propaganda since the the mechanism and
the people are there so they and they
invest lot of money up some size of
roughly 1 1 billion - maybe more US
dollars into the apprai operations and
the information here information the
main it also applies to the diplomatic
efforts which should be addressed and
I'm rooting to that well
on to the military's dime dime paradigm
which is those four became full
instruments of power of every state
which can it should be used to promote
and to defend their issues but on the
other hand when it comes to the on one
side we have Russia alone or trying to
arrange some some unions of of
convenience with China with all Turkey
for this reason or maybe Syria Iran even
though they have a great discrepancies
as far as the different policy policy
issues but they are unfortunately very
very skillful in trying to get the
advantage of and trying to widen every
freezer in mind the the alliances and so
far they were successful in doing this
in Europe and even ambassador alluded to
the fact that no liberal democracies
even though he didn't name the those
countries so everybody understand who
they were active against Ukrainian
values and even though I I concentrated
my my presentation on the military side
of the dime paradigm I didn't I didn't
mean to to say that Russia will attack
Ukraine or further the NATO countries
right the way out in a matter of months
of days no what I meant that they are
preparing all the possibility
capabilities and finding their
capability and all four four domains and
so the response should be first as an
alliance with those alliance of do of
certain values and we understand that
the clash even though it might be called
Ukrainian conference it's we see it as a
conference of enter civilizational
because we are on the other part we used
to be part of the Soviet Union and now
we understand what it means what it
meant to be on the opposite side when
the power of the propaganda mill termite
economic pressure just unleashed on your
country as a matter of policy and so
again Alliance is clear understanding
and alliance of values this date will be
my response yeah thank thank you for
that and mentioning that with this not
big budget 44 billion for Russia of
course they are looking for non-linear
actions and not symmetric actions that's
why they are using information go for
cyber war for whatever and it demands
from from from the liberal democratic
war to find the same the same actions
what to do and that's why very important
that you you focus on the values value
should should prevail in that mmm in
that competition as it as it did as i
did during the the cold war on
confrontation and so on with values
gained you have a question about how it
seems their their investment and their
initiatives in the energy industry
sometimes seem to counter the
initiatives are taking in the asymmetric
and nonlinear military what i mean by
that is to say what we're seeing based
on some of the military activity is some
of the European nations diversify their
LPG reliance
samples are developing terminals of any
in the States because of their the
discomfort with the pressure that Russia
is placing on on European nations
meanwhile there they're simultaneously
developing their energy sector at the
same rate that they have in years if not
more so as you cruise state so I guess
my question is are those two things
somehow synchronized together or is it
possible that there's two separate
strategies coming out of two separate
sectors from the Russian yep well here
do I'm not an expert in the energy Wars
but my country was involved so what we
were made to become such such experts
and I would argue that I I see no
discrepancies as far as though first I
would agree that they were mentioning
mentioned that Putin's regime is has no
clear clear strategy unless it's and
strategy opportunities they they try to
and some some call mr. Putin as a
opportunists right right rightly so and
I would say that again as we see it the
very regime I mean how did they ranged
Putin any and all those around him is
the sort of we would call it as a sort
of corporation whereas the the leader is
can allow some some vessels to round him
to to use to perform some projects and
you are responsible for this project if
you were successful you are we are still
in in the circle if you are you're not
you're out so in some sense you might
have spotted the discrepancies of
results of those who were involved in
different projects as I would argue that
different circles around Putin would be
responsible for different actions but
the the main and the line in ground of
those efforts of those efforts are the
war that war with the world
I mean at least at the Western world and
that is why they did odd-even they as we
called in my country you're trying to
play by the rules in chess but do you
play with like baseball something very
very we were shooting range with you so
they don't care about the values even
though they played the worlds with the
values so I would agree that what you
have supported as the discrepancies of
different performances but in the nod in
in general speaking it's the same the
same strategy of opportunities trying to
find that every time they're trying to
get an advantage to get advantage over
in each and every situation even the
best of the Sergei would would probably
concur with me that even in New Year in
the end every time at every meeting in
to them if you have Russian
representative what would he or she will
be doing she he or she will listen to
everybody speeches and then will make a
presentation a statement of any sort it
should be but it should it should be
there they should pronounce anything
that opposite to any anybody but that's
their direct very presence
that's what and they same they try apply
to the all different operations if their
answer to a question okay you then you
and you and then you be the last
yes thank you it's so much ambassador
and I out of watching the INF treaty
what do you think will mean for dog area
and general Kravitz you mentioned that
Russia is preparing its economy for war
I think this is a unfair question to you
because you're in the military but what
signs do you see for that what are the
symptoms well thank you for the question
the INF treaty it's clear that without
the treaty the risks are growing for
Bulgaria not only for Bulgaria for
Europe this treaty was designed as a
guarantee for Europe mainly and now we
understand it's not gonna be there
anymore
we're not happy we are very much
concerned we tried a lot to persuade our
American allies and the Russian
Federation to think twice but the
problem is that the Russian Federation
did not comply with the treaty and here
it gets very complicated why because the
the essence of non-compliance with the
treaty is top-secret and our American
allies can share it with us only
confidentially so we are kind of blind
here at the United Nations we know that
Russia they are evident there is
evidence that Russia does not comply
with the treaty but at the same time we
don't know why my colleagues at NATO
know why I here
let's say that officially don't know now
without a treaty without a treaty the
risks are growing and at the end of the
day it is also true that the USA America
is also interested to get out of the
treaty and not only because of the
Russian non-compliance but because of
developments in Asia at the end of the
day as I said in my presentation one of
the main challenges the center of
gravity is shifting from west to east by
the way I would agree with that with
that estimate as far as because if there
is no such a treaty it would open up at
the pandora boxx of those countries who
can have any missile production
capability would come up with the
effective missile weaponry and will
threaten neighbors and will decide their
problems with the they will have an edge
to decide on with the weapon my hand and
respond to your question as far as the
how and what we see the question the
response is very very military but
that's what we saw what we support when
we monitor the Russian training
strategic training exercises from year
to year and you know that every year
Russia has its own strategic exercise
even though it's usually official
declared for a couple of weeks in
essence it's a exercise which involves
roughly one at least two military
districts with with what with fleets
with everything and the last several
exercise the ridging exercise
had as an agenda of mastering their
mobilization mobilization and also the
the economy mobilization they we try the
tried at least it was rivet in 2018
last year exercise it was a was talk
2018 before that was upward so it's a
it's a new a new feature of their
exercises which they practice how the
economy should be mobilized and they and
again what I'm trying to convey and I
would give you an example an anecdote
actually that's on the one hand the
dress up I referred already to that 8th
army but again why the name of the 8th
army it's and if you find if you look to
the history you found that you will find
out that the fifth army was created
actually was created in Russia but it
was real reformed in the eastern part of
Ukraine and went through all in the
second world to to to Berlin and it was
a part of the document force in and then
it was taken again after the
reunification of Germany it was
disbanded so it was formed again and in
the 20th summer which is the Western
mutual district there is a 144th
division which is enclosed with now
stationed in close proximity to Ukraine
it's some of the regiment's is 25:32 the
kilometers again what's the name of it
is the very division the soldiers of
which put up the so-called the flag the
banner of victory over Rick's tagging in
Berlin so every in every you know
political indoctrination office there is
the saying our ancestors did it we would
repeat it that's for what they are doing
that the same applies to the so they do
not invent
I mean they don't have to invent the
wheel they already there and that's what
the main idea of my presentation that
they were very serious about getting
prepared for the war and it means that
all the whole variety will not only the
military but also they a nutshell the
answer to a question the several
strategic exercises had a portion of
economy mobilization training that does
the dance of the question how we assess
they are preparing for the the economy
for the time of war even though there
won't be war to tomorrow but the day
after tomorrow but they are they are
serious and they spend some money on
this because they see it as appropriate
at that very moment even though they may
put some efforts and resources in the
West and the thousand West but they
clean for god we forgot about the
Chinese threat actual because you
understand that that forest of Russia is
a Chinese and a lot of Chinese Akoo
settled there so they they would we
would argue that they would have to look
the other way not the Western way but
they they chose so thank you few few
questions but try to be concise well
good afternoon my name is Ron Nabil and
I'm a graduate student in global affairs
given the growing Chinese interest in
the Black Sea region especially in
Albania for instance I was wondering if
you could tell us about the
opportunities you see in China as a
possible economic and military
counterweight to Russia and Turkey
well in my presentation when I mentioned
the main players I put a question mark
on China China as I said is the only
country with global strategy nowadays
so they clearly are pushing quests but
militarily not yet right now we are
talking about infrastructure projects
investment purchases because many
Chinese companies acquired actually some
of the signature European companies in
many sectors it's not only Albania it's
not only Albania as I as I mentioned my
country has been approached to be part
of the belt and Road initiative we said
no for the time being for the time being
because the opportunities the economic
and financial benefits from that
cooperation are there together with the
benefits come some liabilities and now
it is the job of the policy makers and
decision makers in each and every
country to counter whether the benefits
are more than the liabilities in our
case we thought we decided that the
liabilities are more the Italians
decided otherwise military minute there
is no there is no military cooperation
with China in map to my humble knowledge
by any of the countries littoral
countries in the black region so far I
know thank you your question I have a
question about I was a little confused
by what you mean that energy security in
Europe
so if Russians wanna sell gas and
building more pipes from my point of
view it makes more reliable delivery of
the gas to the Europe if Macedonia
doesn't have any other source of gas
why don't they buy our American liquid
gas
so that would be diversified right with
you gas sources or so what's wrong with
building more pipes because from
economical point of view I think that's
provide more security because you have
more points of delivery of the gas and
if you don't have other sources how else
you can do or if that gas is cheaper
than liquid gas tribute to you when of
course you know saving country yeah
can you just explain me I will I will I
will now look the it is interdependence
it is energy independence when we're
talking about energy and exactly gas not
oil gas this is the thing now Europe
benefits by getting gas Russia benefits
by getting money everything is okay
right
yes but monopole ism is not good
monopolies 'm is not good that's why can
you tell me why it is Russian policy to
offer different prices sometimes up to
50% higher or lower to European
countries what is the rationale behind
it it's market no it's not if you don't
know it's not politics it's exactly
politics you know it is leverage it is
leverage it is pressure it is pressure
and this is what we don't like we will
love Russian gas you know there is a
sink in Europe that in every basement in
Europe there is a Russian switching the
heating on and off and that's true make
themselves make yourself switching it on
and off you don't like we don't have the
resolutions it's more expensive it's
more expensive it's more expensive so
you don't like the price no that's it
difference no no no no no no don't
misunderstand me don't misunderstand me
they are alternatives the thing is there
are alternatives from Azerbaijan for
example right by it
it is it is coming now we are working on
it we're diversifying both the suppliers
and the transient roles it's coming yeah
we're working on this but for the time
being the status quo is as I said yeah
but then explain me what's wrong if you
go into I guess it was explained that
monopoly because rush arrives the prior
it's the prior NZ tour and Wix editor
and how make it not monopoly because
they actually taking that gas from
whatever they taken it's they want to be
the supplier the transit er and
distributor this is what European Union
is opposing together with don't
understand it
okay we are pressed by the time can you
can you can you push monopolies which is
which is very challenging I want to
thank the ambassador in the general very
interesting presentations my question
has to do with Nadel it seems to me
listening to the presentations that NATO
is largely blamed for the current
situation and this build-up and the
activity of the Russian Federation and
the Russian forces in the Black Sea you
had plenty of warning I'm talking about
NATO you had Georgia you had the
annexation of Crimea the forceful
annexation you have NATO countries right
on the Black Sea Turkey had as the
Ambassador mentioned has a large
military and a large naval force also
and it seems that NATO could have been
much more assertive at the outset even
know forget about Georgia but certainly
with the annexation of Crimea the right
were all over the place and and the
current situation in the Black Sea I
feel is largely the result of lack of
NATO initiative to stabilize the
situation especially on the border of
NATO countries and so I'm happy to hear
that NATO is finally taking a more
active role but I'd like to hear your
opinion about specifically what they
could do militarily I understand
longer-term values and the predominance
of you know Western values may have an
influence but they seem short-term there
has to be some kind of strong and very
forceful NATO response and even a NATO
presence to least stabilize a situation
to prevent it from getting worse and I'd
like to hear your opinion about what
NATO might be able to do okay I can't
like but we are not a member of NATO so
I'll compliment actually what I would I
would agree that read is not NATO is not
blind but it's more slow slow in
response and we both know us probably
heard about this NATO coming up with
some some response as far as the Black
Sea region and I don't personally I
don't know the specifics of that of that
program but I would argue that they will
probably need the present naval presence
in Black Sea and as the Ambassador
alluded to that that the Metro
Convention
steps in I mean Turkey would do probably
Russia will will certainly be opposed to
to any expansion of naval presence made
a naval presence in the Black Sea on the
other hand would they do on the eastern
flank
like in Poland
mania and for my country is good because
what we try to get from NATO's that we
weeks to try to explain to them that
we'll do our our part of job give us
give us the weapons give us enough
wherewithal
we will pause the the aggression and
this is this the main the main point of
discussion between between Ukraine and
NATO and there was an allusion to that
UN mission to Ukraine I would like to to
pronounce it since its I think it's
really growing understanding that there
is no military way out of the conflict
international conference I would argue
and in Ukraine and this is the the next
sort of the oldest discussion because
we're in this case NATO if it could have
some some leverage there was a mention
of OC as a revival has revived abruptly
revived because of that the conflict in
Ukraine so I would argue that again what
I try to convey when I mentioned the
values that without the well is because
if you are talking only capitalism one
of the prices and the benefits you would
will forget that with the benefits of
values if you put them aside they will
be used will be used by by the opponent
of those who cherish and other values
that's what was my point but militarily
again NATO unfortunate is little bit
slow but it's it takes time for the name
that's the way I see it well I'll be
very concise I'll try to at least you
know it is not that NATO underestimated
Russia no not at all the geopolitical
situation was different
and of the fall after the fall of the
Soviet Union you remember we had that
president Boris Yeltsin he was the best
body with Bill Clinton and the
cooperation was quite significant
at that time ambassador I hope you would
agree with me that the Security Council
of the United Nations for the first time
started to work as a peace builder why
because the two powers the two big
powers America and the Soviet Union and
Russia they had good understanding
between each other that's why the
Security Council of the United Nation
started to function to be a peace
builder which is actually the purpose it
has been created for now NATO did not
understand why Russia the geopolitical
situation was different and after that
as I mentioned the Russian Black Sea
Fleet was not that powerful as it is
today and as it will be in couple of
years because they are commissioning new
vessels new aircrafts new weapons
everything I'm not sure whether they
have nuclear weapons there but I do know
as far as Crimea don't yet they have the
capabilities to queuesession them
exactly so the situation changed and in
this changed the situation I do remember
the russian-georgian war from 2008 it
was discussed at NATO what can we do in
the Black Sea but at that time there was
no appetite to explore options how to
increase NATO's presence in Black Sea
because Georgia has been considered an
isolated case that is not correct that
is not correct but it has been
considered an isolated case and the
Montreal Convention it is the convention
you cannot enter the Black Sea with a
military ship and stay there stay there
longer than 45 days so what can we do
rotate ships that is one option the
other option is the
NATO littoral states namely Turkey
Bulgaria and Romania to acquire
sophisticated capabilities in the Black
Sea
I mean naval capabilities well how to do
that
we Bulgaria we hit with very inventive
you know we had that idea we hit that
idea of the so called cascade process I
mean for example vessels decommissioned
by the United States to be given to us
dude
to use them but that idea somehow for
some reasons was not welcome very much
and I agree that this is not the best
solution but we must do something I
don't know why what we have to be
inventive to think out of the box I
mentioned few of the options they are on
the table one of them or combination
it's the only way last question and so
thank you so much for being here this is
a very important topic to increase the
awareness among Ivy League schools and
my question is I'm trying to look into
the future yes so I'm very well aware of
what is going on now or what was before
several years ago but we students here
sooner or later we need to make a
decision whether we want to go back
whether we are going back actually to
the Black Sea region and what do you
think about the perspective of the
region not only I'm thinking about
Ukrainian complaint I'm thinking about
Eastern Central Europe and Western
Europe as well because overall situation
there is not the best so I would
appreciate your thoughts Thanks well no
this time I'll be very concise very now
look I'll share with you the dream of my
prime minister
Boyko Borissov his dream is that in the
Black Sea we should have a lot of
tourists a lot of yachts
so prosperity free movement and
pipelines so I really want we'll walk
work for that that not to allow the
Black Sea region to turn into a zone of
conflict that's it thank you today ok I
can't react I I agree that it should be
the surah of touristic opportunities in
my country and say in Ukrainian Crimea
would different tourists with no Russian
presence military presence that's the
future for my country first of all it's
important to reconstruct the the trust
which is lost totally lost three
consider the confidence so in the region
there are a lot of institutions which
were built and founded just to to have
to have a confidence in the confidence
building I was a part of that when we
created the Black Sea force we signed of
the so long ago
but it was created just for the
confidence and many institutions of the
kind
European Union synergy projects there is
just about that so what is needed to
come back to the to the trust which is
lost totally lost well thank you very
much for your questions for attendance
well all those who are watching us now
thank you to be with us today and thank
you
[Music]